monday p-f-t-o-t
there is so much to discuss on these
football mondays coming out of a slate
we needed over time well we need it
every day but we definitely need it
today let's start with the last thing we
discussed on pft live okay we have some
more thoughts and i'm trying to draw him
out of you you're being a little
circumspect you don't want to piss off
jalen ramsey but you and i are both of
the minds yes that is a bad look for a
guy who clearly wants to be traded right
the team is trying to not trade him
they're trying to get through this ugly
period he calls in sick which is a load
of crap right if you're sick they got
all kind of drugs there they can get you
better they'll give you a shot if you
need a shot you show up for work in the
national football league you've got sam
darnold with mononucleosis or as you
would say mononucleosis who is champion
at the bit to show up at work even
though he's got an enlarged spleen he
wants to go play this is this is the
kind of thing that can get players
to turn on jaylen ramsey am i right well
i can get everybody to turn on that's
why i i don't want to see him do this i
do think he's taking the wrong approach
i am a huge jalen ramsey fan and uh you
know he is the best corner in football
and he could have been a pain in the
butt this whole offseason and demanded a
new contract and made issues that way
but he's been professional and because
of that you know uh he's he's i think
you know looked at it as kind of a
professional type of guy but when you do
stuff like this you know then you lose
the perception becomes reality to a
degree here at some point where people
are going to look at jalen ramsey oh you
know here he is another diva cornerback
or you know another guy that you know
not lean he's not he's not liking what
he's getting so he's gonna you know
complain and and be an annoyance that
way you know there's other ways to do it
go to practice go there you can say my
hamstring's tight i can't practice today
you could say that all day all week all
week long whatever it may be but it is
not a good look and i just yeah i always
err on the
side of the player and uh i i just think
there's a better way to do this he
should have just held out yeah it's too
late now yeah that's the thing the way
the cba is set up
if you don't show up you have much
greater leverage than if you show up and
leave because if you show up and leave
if they if they decide at some point to
put him on the left squad list he's shut
down for the year he can't play for
anybody he ain't getting traded he ain't
getting any money he ain't getting
anything and and the problem is he's
dealing with tom coughlin yeah who may
not be as compliant as other teams have
been there's this whole push from
nfl players to become like nba players
and tom coughlin's the last guy to mess
with on something like this you don't
want to turn it into a battle of wills
and you don't want to turn it into who's
going to blink and you don't want this
thing to keep ratcheting up and
ratcheting up and
ramsay's camp is trying to put pressure
and push buttons and i i don't i don't
know what they expect the reaction to be
here but i guarantee you it is not going
to be a good reaction from tom coughlin
to the idea that jaylen ramsey is too
sick to come to work guys come to work
with all sorts of injuries and ailments
and they get them treated
at work they work in a place that is
there in large part the training
facility to get the guys ready to go
yeah they've got every medication he
could possibly need to make him feel
better and make his symptoms go away
well and you'll sometimes you know
within this too i mean you're right
you're spot on about all that and then
you know also those teams that might be
on the fence about trading for them
right they go oh man you know especially
with antonio brown being so relevant and
the pain in the butt he's been you know
you might not win your yourself the
benefit of the doubt with certain
football teams uh so yeah i think the
big thing is yes show up uh continue to
voice your displeasure with being there
you can continue to voice your
displeasure as being a part of the team
you want out of there is anybody gonna
make a move though that's the big thing
mike who is it gonna be like the ravens
yesterday did they get off the field
yesterday and go you know what we're
never gonna beat kansas city and patrick
mahomes unless we get another guy in
here to help us i would think that
thought has to go through their head the
eagles same thing i mean how many weeks
in a row are we gonna watch them get
burned by big pass plays and you know
there is no pass rush in philadelphia so
if you don't have a bass rush and you
can't cover somebody that's problem
the jaguars bears some blame here too
because apart from mismanaging the
relationship with jaylen ramsey once he
made the trade demand last week that's
when you slam the door you you when you
begin to entertain what it would take to
move on and what you what you would want
that's when you create an expectation
it's going to happen right and for a
period of time last week
tuesday wednesday thursday
against the titans yeah i remember
janelle ramsey's quote he kind of had
that smile like yeah as long as i'm here
i'm happy he thinks he's getting out
once you think you're getting out and
they keep you in
it does make things worse the the
jaguars should have made it clear from
the get-go we're not trading this guy
we're not period i keep trying to get
out and they keep pulling me back in
close enough
not
available
as of saturday three teams were
interested pending the outcome of the
nfl's investigation
as of sunday tweetstorm goes after
robert kraft goes after big ben says
he's done playing in the nfl when after
robert klemco the guy from si.com who
had the story last week that really was
that last domino that last push that a
few days later antonio's fired by the
patriots you know i knew he wasn't going
to stay on the high road for long and i
think anybody who's thinking about
signing antonio brown is watching what
he's doing but still people are gonna be
seduced by the talent i i think that at
some point once he
unless he's banished for life which
could happen if the nfl decides that
brittany taylor is telling an accurate
and truthful story about being forcibly
raped by antonio brown i think he's
banished for life
but something short of that a suspension
10 games eight games six games whatever
i you know i'm surprised somebody hasn't
signed him to a contract just to secure
dibs on him for whenever he's clear like
washington did last year when they
claimed ruben foster on waivers knowing
at some point we're going to get the
benefit of this yeah okay yeah well it
wasn't a good look for the redskins at
that point and i think with antonio
brown right now you got to be scared
like what else is going to come out
right i mean i think that's the big
thing uh i just can't imagine
anybody would be crazy enough to sign
him until some of this stuff gets
settled right mike i mean to me that
just would be insane i mean i would i
would really argue if you're crazier
than antonio brown if you sign antonio
brown right now i mean i just don't even
understand how that could be a thought
uh you got to let this whole thing flush
itself out figure out where it stands
with the nfl you know uh with law
officials whatever it may be but i
wouldn't touch antonio brown but that's
the thing there's no criminal case
but they interviewed brittany taylor
last week for 10 hours and like it's
impossible to keep this stuff completely
quiet maybe there's some chatter making
the rounds that she's telling a
persuasive story uh or or not but but
but here's the thing i keep coming back
to and we see it in the impulsive
behavior of antonio brown when it's time
for him to sit across from the table and
be interrogated by someone from the
league yeah i hear you mike he is going
to snap at some point yeah the emotions
he is not going to be a good witness
he's going to be colonel nathan jessup
you know who that is absolutely not a
few good men right jack nicholson you
betcha your damn right eye dude well you
know i didn't order the code red at some
point antonio brown
is going to snap on whoever is asking
him questions and and it's it's
unfortunate i've seen this when i was
practicing law you can have people who
are extremely good liars very persuasive
you can also have people who are
horrible truth tellers and antonio brown
may be completely innocent but because
of how he is because of how he's wired
he is not going to be able to sit there
and submit right right that all of this
flows from
and
i i i know that that you've defended
mike tomlin but mike tomlin enabled this
guy mike tomlin created this guy by
letting him get what he wanted over and
over again and i'm on record last week
saying when you have a great player you
got to do what it takes to make him
happy yeah this is what happens when you
take it to the extreme yeah right
because he's never heard no he's never
been made accountable the most
accountable anyone ever made him was the
patriots firing him on friday night
because the first time he was fired by a
team this year and he didn't want to be
right so uh this is going to be tough
for him and when it's time for him to
talk to the league i think it's going to
go sideways and who knows what the
league's ultimately going to decide like
i said if they decide he raped brittany
taylor
i think the only appropriate outcome is
to ban him for life ah yeah i mean i i'm
with you there i mean if that that's
what happened that's the allegation yeah
i mean if they decide that she's telling
the truth right even without a criminal
charge right if they decide we talked to
her we talked to him we ran down the
other evidence and we think she's
telling the truth he's done out of the
fact that they've seen his texts this
past weekend of him bullying you know
another person who of course just added
more fuel to the fire so i would think
so too if they feel that that he did do
that uh that he would be in deep trouble
of never playing ever again all right we
talked about the browns rams game we
talked about it from the perspective of
freddie kitchens from baker mayfield one
guy who i think is critical to whether
or not this experiment is going to work
in cleveland is receiver odell beckham
jr
he said after the game i don't want to
give an excuse that we're a young team
and we're fresh and new together but
we're still trying to find ourselves and
find our identity and that gets right to
what you are saying that right what are
you going to do on offense how's the
offense going to run right is it going
to be feed the ball to odell beckham jr
is it going to be 25 carries to nick
chubb what is the central theme of your
offense that's a fair criticism that i
think you've made very appropriately as
it relates to the bears and now it
applies to the browns what is it going
to be where is that identity so what
would you say it should be based upon
the personnel the browns have yeah i i
mean to me it's one of two things it's
either okay we're gonna get a little
smash mouth football and pull guards and
play that style of football and kind of
impose our will that way and then when
we get a favorable match up one-on-one
outside we're going to hit odell beckham
jr on a go route or a 20-yard comeback
route or something like that it's either
that or you make it all about odell
beckham jr that would be the one or two
things that i look at to go this is
where they can force a defense's hand to
go oh gosh they're really good at this
thing and now we have to change our
defensive calls to stop that so whether
that's run the game run the ball ground
and pound let's get underneath the
center which they did more of last year
when freddie kitchens took over you know
i think last night he was trying to show
his patients with the run game because
he knew he couldn't pass protect against
that rams defensive line that was scary
but yeah i think it's one of those two
things mike whether they want to decide
they want to be a running team first and
rely on that and then you load the box
and they take advantage on the outside
or do they just go you know what we got
this damn receiver odell beckham jr and
i'm going to have 30 different ways to
get him the ball every week and we're
going to get him the ball and get it
going that way and see if teams then
start to go oh we need to double him or
we need to play this coverage because
they're doing this with odell and then
you play off of it but right now it's
just a lot of plays and a lot of
formations and sometimes it looks cool
and a lot of other times it looks kind
of
they've got to do something because even
the night that they won seven days ago
against the jets it felt sluggish there
was a lot of ends with a big splash play
right there and and they should have put
the jets away early they should have won
that game by 40 points just because
they're one and two look they got the
ravens coming up they got the 49ers
coming up the schedule we talked about
this during the show it stays difficult
until week 10. and after that it gets
very soft they need to be not so far
behind the ravens by week 10 that they
can start knocking out teams like the
steelers which is still so weird to me
that they're considered a bad team but
they are they are steelers dolphins uh
they've got uh who else on the schedule
they've got some games they should look
at the bangles twice the bengals twice
that's the other one yeah the other bad
team oh and three as well all right
speaking of the steelers and speaking of
identity yeah the steelers would like to
run the ball the steelers can't run the
ball because they're getting eight-man
fronts plus because they can't throw the
ball right and james connor who was
great
when le'veon bell was on the team but
not with the team
james connor has been uh
a disappointment so far this year he's
got a total of i've got it right here 97
rushing yards through three games 34
carries that's 2.9 yards per carry
yesterday against san francisco 13 for
43
which look look if you and jalen samuels
didn't do anything
uh the rookie didn't do anything the
kids from kentucky snell benny snell
right and uh
when
you don't this this goes back to antonio
brown maybe they're the ones that should
sign antonio brown when you don't have
antonio brown and juju smith-schuster's
not stepping into that role the way that
he needs to and you don't have ben
roethlisberger you're not gonna be able
to run the ball no i i think that's uh i
mean you hit i think on all the
appropriate points along with also
mike munchek not being there anymore on
the offensive line i think that's
another whammy to the the whole psyche
of what they're able to do in the run
game but the big thing is exactly what
you're saying mike i mean you know they
haven't been playing good defense so
they've been behind in football games
they haven't been able to stay patient
with the run game they're not really a
run first team as of last year and this
year yes now there's like you said mike
you hit it there's no big bend to worry
about oh gosh he can throw 50 yard bombs
over our head there's no antonio brown
to go oh gosh we better keep people deep
because he can run by us for 50 yard
bombs over our head uh and james connor
is not le'veon bell you know he's a
solid running back but he's not like
special by any stretch of the
imagination and yeah they're they're um
their offense is not pretty and i you
know and again i don't think mason
rudolph is going to scare anybody either
you know yeah double mover touchdown
deep cross or juju smith for a touchdown
everything other than that was pretty
damn average and i just don't see how
this steelers offense can really
create any magic this year i would be
shocked if they became anything special
they're just kind of middle of the road
bottom of the league well and as these
losses pile up uh
they're going to get louder and louder
and yeah they are and it's it's not a
good year for the steelers and not that
they're going to fire mike tomlin but
the steelers fans are going to and
look i i
i can't imagine steelers fans turning
away from the team and not going to
games but if it ever becomes a business
type thing where they're not making
money because then you will see some
some major changes right so yeah
they're in trouble and i mean i know we
weren't expecting this for sure i mean
the defense has been all over the place
we're seeing the issues with covering
people once again i mean they couldn't
stop the run yesterday with the san
francisco 49ers as close as that game
was you know yesterday the 49ers had
their way with the pittsburgh steelers
and the offensive side of the ball and
pittsburgh i mean was playing all out i
mean stefan tua and cam hayward and and
company i mean they were all over the
field because they got beast on that
side of the ball but what's happening
too is their schemes getting exposed run
game pass game uh that's what we're
seeing we've never seen the steelers
defense get diced up the way it has
these first three weeks of the year it's
been a long long time at least all right
that's it for pftot we'll be back with
pft live tomorrow we'll keep rolling
with pftot chris sims unbutton later
today you're gonna do two games deep
dives based upon what the fans want yep
and double at pft pm tomorrow lots of
stuff going on as we close the books on
week three and move to we toward week
four everybody have a great day
you'd like to move to week i would like
to let's do that now in fact move
forward
we'll see everybody have a great day
you